okay so in this video I want to talk
about this
of enzymes and the reason why really is
to just allow you to basically when you
see an enzyme in its name to kind of get
an idea of how that enzyme actually
functions okay it's really really
helpful to keep all this stuff in mind
okay so first endline class is oxido
reductase
so oxido reductase is the reactions they
catalyze are oxidation reduction
reactions or redox reactions when they
actually tells you a lot they're oxido
reductase oxidation reduction so the
catalyzed electron transfers of course
the redox reactions are and I put often
with H here because basically when it
comes to redox reactions and
biochemistry it's tough to kind of see
where the electrons are going so it's
easier to track the hydrogen the gain of
hydrogen's or the gain of bonds to
hydrogen is a reduction and the loss of
bonds to hydrogen is an oxidation so
that's typically low to keep in mind so
an example here of lactate dehydrogenase
turning pyruvate into lactate and this
reaction is reversible but we can see
here that the key difference between
these two molecules is right here if
carbonyl there where it is here we have
an alcohol and basically we gained two
hydrogen's going from pyruvate to
lactate so pyruvate was reduced because
it got these two hydrogen's attached to
it to be turned into lactate and since
pyruvate was reduced NADH lost its
hydrogen and therefore was oxidized so
that's a redox reaction there and it
catalyzed by a dehydrogenase or
dehydrogenase
I typically pronounce it two hydrogenase
but if you see a dehydrogenase which is
associate that with redox reactions so
here this actually this this enzyme was
named for the reverse reaction but the
point is that if you see dehydrogenase
you should associate that with redox
reactions okay so a lot of
oxidoreductases will have that they'll
be called dehydrogenases like lactate
dehydrogenase which just shows up in
fermentation you also might come across
oxidases like lysyl oxidase and that
should make sense you have an oxidation
occurring life´s law oxidation shows up
in collagen synthesis
hmg-coa reductase so it's a reduction
reaction and that that that enzyme is
you catalyzes the rate limiting step of
cholesterol synthesis
okay so the point is though if you see a
dehydrogenase an oxidation reductase
there's a redox reaction happening and
that's something to pay attention to
okay all right so next up transfer aces
so transpiration they transfer
functional groups they catalyze
functional group transfer so literally
telling you exactly what it does okay
let the names kind of speak to you so it
can transfer an amino group of CO group
methyl group really any functional group
okay and so here we have a
transamination reaction catalyzed by a
transaminase the trans in it should tell
you that it's transferring something in
fact it's here is telling you it's
transferring an amino group or amino
transferase and it's acting with alanine
alland immunity amino acid here so
specifically what's happening here is
that we're starting off with pyruvate
and glutamate and what's happening is
that pyruvate has this carbonyl group
and glutamate has this amino group
basically glutamate is going to give it
to me no group in this hydrogen to
pyruvate and pyruvate is going to give
us carbonyl group to two glutamate and
so what ends up happening is that good
to make it turned into alpha
ketoglutarate right there it's got the
ketone and the pyruvate now has that
amino group the whole idea was that we
simply transferred that amino group okay
in this reaction PLP is your paradox
with phosphate is used as a cofactor how
about that later anyway the point is
that amino transferase is transfer amino
groups they're also called trans
laminations you see a lot of that in a
lot of those in nitrogen metabolism and
that should make sense amino groups have
nitrogen to them
hexokinase is it's not explicitly
mentioned as transferase but these guys
specifically add phosphate groups from
ATP or GTP and exocrine so in glycolysis
polymerase DNA polymerase RNA polymerase
they transfer nucleoside triphosphates
or deoxynucleotide triphosphates
methyl transferases transfer methyl
groups
and they're all over the place
methyltransferases
you